hey my name is Samuel Leeds I'm a
property investor and thank you so much
for your support throughout this timing
lockdown it's been a really challenging
interesting time and many people have
been saying to me samuel is property
investing over you know listen I don't
believe for a minute there's not even a
tiny little bit of me they don't even a
piece of my bone that thinks the
property investing is over right now I'm
actually really on a business level I'm
really really excited about property at
the moment more than I've been in a long
time I've been doing more deals I've
been on the phone I'm ridiculously
excited so I wanted to do an update just
to answer all the questions that I've
been having about really every single
strategy people have been saying is buy
refurbish refinance still possible is
serviced accommodation still happening
rent to rent HMOs lease option agreement
deal packaging I buy-to-let generally is
it over like what's what what's
happening and I wanted to address that
because I know it's gonna happen more
and more you know why because in 2008
the amount of times in 2008 I heard
people saying the day's a property
investing are over I was even worried I
was just a kid I just bought my third
property and I'm thinking is this all
over and and and as time went on and I
began to learn more and I became more
aware I realized actually you don't need
to listen to what the average person
saying what you need to do is you just
need to think use your brain
listen to the rich people and look at
history so I want to share openly with
you about what I think is going to
happen to the market what strategies are
still good I want to talk about me like
what I'm doing what's going on my
youtube channel I mean people have been
saying Samuel are you okay what why are
you not doing as many videos what's
happening what's going on so this is
really just an update video to say no
it's not all over in fact this is the
beginning of a new massive exciting
season because buy-to-let know it's not
over people that are saying put your
money in the bank and save your pennies
or losers because they're printing money
and they're not building more land so
I'd rather have my money in property
than in the bank even if there's going
to be a small dip this year 100% I've
been investing now for over a decade
service accommodations taking a little
hit it is but it's gonna pick back up of
course is taking a hit because bucking
calm aren't taking bookings right now
people can't go and stay at hotels
of course he's taken a hair but when
lockdown finishes what's gonna happen
it's gonna come up again
and all the people that gave their keys
back to the landlord's summerling
there's going to be much less supply and
the demand is going to come back so
now's the opportunity to seize the day
buy refurbish refinance be careful okay
be careful
but buy refurbish refinance I've just
been speaking to a guy recently who's
what are doing a buyer refurbished
refinance property one of my students
yesterday in fact another one just came
in today and they're getting the
refinance on a commercial value and the
commercial values based on rents and
rent on dairy down you just got to be
smart
yes bricks and mortar might drop a
little bit but how can how can you be
smart how can you be smart in this
season and I'll tell you something if
you do buy refurbish refinance getting
builders to go out for good prices is
easier than ever getting bargain
properties to begin with is easier than
ever and they're the only three figures
you need to look at purchase price
refurb cost and value so as long as you
do it smart and you can really kill it
with that strategy right now lease
option agreements I don't even want to
get started I'm have to save that for
other videos because that's the strategy
right now that's the thing that's the
thing deal packaging people are saying
oh you can't do it people are doing it
I'm gonna bring them onto my youtube
channel
I can't officially do windows Wednesday
right now because when is Wednesday is a
whole experience where I have people
down to my office I meet them we go out
for dinner and I can't do that right now
but what I'm gonna do instead and also I
had windows Wednesday students lined up
for like months and I didn't want to
even do it on a zoom call because if I
did it on a zoom call number one it kind
of kills the whole good feeling that
they have when they come to our office
and we meet and everything but secondly
I didn't want to share stories with you
about look this person became
financially free three months ago and
then then you're thinking yeah but that
was three months ago what about now I
want a one thing I want to keep the
content right now really up to date so
I'm probably gonna see how though guys
get on until after lockdown until after
this and then I'll bring them back on
winners Wednesday and during this
epidemic at the moment what I want to do
is I just want
bring people on YouTube that are doing
deals right now and I've been speaking I
spoke to six people just yesterday that
are making money through deal packaging
right now one guy just said he's making
more money in lockdown than he wasn't is
a nine-to-five job like the stories are
fantastic and phenomenal so you have a
choice as one of my subscribers you have
a choice you can either be a doubter and
you can be someone that thinks and be
scared but fear never helps anything or
you can be creative and being an
entrepreneur and say there's a wind
right now but how can I set my sail you
can say the economy is changing right
now but how can I create my own economy
so that's what I'm going to be teaching
over the next few weeks from YouTube
albeit I might have to do some of the
recording myself the quality and the
edits might not be as amazing as they
have been because my team aren't working
with me I'm not at the office I'm at my
house someone said to me recently what's
it like living in a big beautiful house
during lockdown because I live in a nice
house I said to be honest you know what
it's great I'm really blessed and
fortunate to live in a good house but
I'm more fortunate to live with good
people and I know that there's some
people right now going through a really
tough time there's people alone not with
their families there's people that are
worried about what's going to happen and
I think I just wanted to really say on a
human level person to person if you're
one of my followers you're one of my
subscribers yeah okay I want you to get
rich yeah I want you become financially
free yeah I want to teach you about
property but I also really genuinely
care about you and if you're in a rough
time right now drop me a message I've
got so much more free time at home on
responding to so many messages on
Instagram on the literally just jump in
doing voice notes to people so you know
wherever you're at whatever you're doing
just know that I want you to do well and
also you know what I think that there's
so much negativity in the media right
now and on the news right now and I just
want to encourage you as well just to
stay positive just stay focused and also
if like if you're feeling if you're
feeling bad about yourself right now
you're feeling bad in this situation
just think actually you know what I'm
not going to think in Woodleigh I'm
gonna think outwardly pick up the phone
and bring three people and tell them
that you love them who you care about
like just use this time to be kind to
spread positivity to spread love
property investing is not over my
youtube channel
my strategies they're just that this is
just the beginning for many things and I
want to say the same for you this is not
the end of your dream to become
financially free this is just the
beginning so guys thank you for
supporting me through this time thank
you for watching this video if you're a
subscriber thank you from the bottom of
my heart if you're not a subscriber
subscribe right now turn on the
notification Bell smash the like button
also I want to know what you want to say
like what kind of videos do you want to
see what kind of content do you want to
see so let me know again in the comments
what do you want to see what videos do
want me to do a lot of time I'm going to
be shooting the videos and posting them
for your benefit to ultimately see your
journey to financial freedom and I can't
wait to meet you one day I can't wait to
have you in when is Wednesday once this
is all over and I'm really rooting for
you so thank you so much I'll see you on
the next video which will be tomorrow
god bless peace out